écoutez merci d'être venu à cette
conférence de presque un peu impromptue
qui qu'on a convoqué très tardivement
mais il nous paraissait important en
effet à l'issue de la commission des
affaires sociales qui s'est réunit cet
après-midi
pendant pendant deux heures c'est et
donc dans la configuration habituelle
des commissions législatives où nous
avons examiné donc le projet loi de
financement de la rectificative de la
sécurité sociale autrement dit le projet
de loi sur la réforme des retraites il
faut savoir que c'est un texte financier
et cet après-midi nous avons voté sur
les amendements proposés par les
rapporteurs et les abdos et René Paul
Savary sur ce texte mais nous n'avons
pas voté sur le texte nous avons voté
sur des amendements relatifs au texte
puisque le texte qui arrivera en séance
à partir de jeudi sera le texte transmis
par le gouvernement contrairement à une
proposition de loi ou un projet de loi
quand la commission formule des
amendements présents des amendements et
les votes nous votants ensuite un texte
que le texte de la commission qui arrive
en séance mais pour les textes
budgétaires c'est le texte initial qui
sera donc examiné à partir de jeudi en
discussion générale le dépôt des
amendements est fixé à demain soir et
nous serons demain soir à 17h combien
d'amendements nous aurons à examiner
d'ici le 12 le 12 mars je voulais
simplement avant de passer la parole au
rapporteurs qui vont décliner les
mesures qu'ils ont souhaité ajouter à ce
texte rappeler que pour nous à chaque
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui est votée au mois
de novembre nous votons depuis plusieurs
années une mesure pour l'équilibre de la
branche vieillesse donc nous sommes
constants dans ce que nous votons depuis
quatre ans et donc constant dans l'idée
en effet d'avoir un texte qui améliore
le solde de la branche vieillesse à
l'horizon 2030 et c'était l'objet de la
maman que nous avions voté
au mois de au mois de novembre sans
succès puisque depuis quatre ans le
gouvernement repoussait cet amendement
nous avions eu droit un texte sur les
retraites en 2020 et déposé au Sénat
parce qu'il avait été voté Assemblée
nationale mais que le gouvernement
choisi de ne pas reprendre pour venir
sur le texte que nous examinons
actuellement donc dans ce dans ce
contexte du mois de novembre nous avions
souhaité en effet que dans le cas d'un
équilibre sert budgétaire soit à tout un
des réflexions et c'était l'objet de
l'abonnement qui avait présenté René
Paul Savary qui avait été votée par la
majorité sénatoriale nous avions
souhaité que soit abordé des sujets tels
que le maintien des seigneurs d'un
emploi tel que l'égalité homme-femme la
pénibilité
les régimes spéciaux donc tout ça était
défini dans au moins dès le mois de
novembre et là nous avons à cette
occasion de de textes de cet après-midi
donner un avis favorable aux amendements
qu'on présenter les rapporteurs avec des
mesures spécifiques sur plusieurs
items que vont vous présenter les
rapporteurs voilà pour présenter le
contexte de ce texte
Elisabeth qui rapporte en général
puisqu'on est sur un texte en effet de
financement de la sécurité sociale
bonsoir à vous toutes et à vous tous je
sais pas si ça fonctionne avec les
micros qui sont plutôt là je préfère moi
c'est plus c'est plus facile en tout cas
j'espère que tous les journalistes qui
nous ont contactés René Paul Savary et
moi-même ces derniers jours vont pouvoir
être présents à cette conférence parce
que nous avons du mal depuis quelques
jours à répondre à vos sollicitations
c'est pas faute de ne pas répondre mais
ces fautes d'avoir assez de temps pour
vous consacrer les réponses qui vous
conviennent donc cette conférence et
bienvenue même si elle est tardive tout
d'abord je voudrais dire combien le
Sénat réclamait un projet de loi
rectificatif depuis quelques temps en
tout cas depuis
l'épreuve que nous avons eu à subir avec
l'épidémie de covid-19 parce que nous
voyons les comptes de la Sécurité
sociale très impactées par les mesures
qui étaient prises ces dernières années
nous ne l'avons pas eu et donc
paradoxalement nous avons un projet de
loi rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui avec cette réforme des
retraites bon nous en prenons acte je
voudrais tout de suite dire que c'est
pour moi quelque chose qui est tout à
fait normal puisque ça va impacter non
pas à court terme mais un moyen et à
long terme les contes de la sécurité
sociale alors pour toute personne qui me
dirait c'est pas le véhicule législatif
qu'il faut moi je dis si c'est le
véhicule législatif tout à fait
approprié parce que c'est une résonance
à une résonance sur les contes de la
sécurité sociale et donc aujourd'hui
nous sommes devant cette réforme des
retraites qui est peu qui a été peu
débattue à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
regrettable mais nous espérons ici au
Sénat que nous irons jusqu'au bout c'est
notre intention parce que il y a dans
cette réforme la mesure d'âge de départ
à la retraite mais il y a aussi des
mesures sociales auxquelles nous sommes
attachés si nous ne votons pas cette
réforme ça veut dire que nous ne votons
pas non plus toutes les mesures je
dirais de justice sociale qui sont
apportées après l'article 7 donc nous
avons soutenu cette réforme comme l'a
dit madame la présidente depuis quatre
années nous l'avons soutenu au cours du
PLFSS nous allons donc la soutenir dans
ce projet de Loire rectificatif avec des
marqueurs du Sénat quels sont ces
marqueurs et bien la première chose à
dire c'est que nous voulons que un
retour à l'équilibre parce que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites nous
l'a fortement indiqué les comptes de la
branche vieillesse sont déficitaires et
durablement déficitaires très très
rapidement et durablement donc nous
devons agir
la prévision d'un déficit à 13,5
milliards en 2030 nous oblige à avoir
cette obligation de soutenabilité
financière la soutenabilité financière
elle assure c'est la condition de la
pérennité du système auquel nous sommes
plus attaché le système de commande de
retraite par répartition je crois que
même ceux qui sont dans la rue ils sont
attachés donc ce que nous voulons c'est
en tout cas assurer sa pérennité parce
que en raison de la démographie nous
voyons bien nous observons bien que
c'est difficile de le maintenir dans la
durée et donc si on est pour cette
réforme de l'âge de départ à la retraite
nous voulons aussi que certains nombre
de propositions soient faites sur le
plan social
le Sénat a été très attentif notamment
aux carrières des femmes notamment par
rapport à ces trimestres qui leur sont
réservés dès lors qu'il y a une
maternité une adoption ou l'éducation
d'un enfant nous estimons
qu'effectivement cette proposition du
gouvernement tel qu'elle est proposée
n'est pas satisfaisante à ce niveau et
donc nous avons souhaité apporter une
modification alors pas tant sur le
nombre d'enfants parce que là on
tomberait probablement dans une
inégalité on peut pas proposer un
amendement qui soit en quelque sorte
j'en Ré et donc nous avons opté pour une
proposition qui est plutôt sur une
surcotte pourquoi parce que la réalité
c'est que les pensions des femmes sont
nettement inférieures aux pensions des
hommes c'est un écart de 25 à 30%. le
fait d'apporter cette surcote et bien
permet de gommer en partie je dis bien
en partie c'est c'est trimestre qui
finalement ne comptait pour moyen à
partir du moment où vous avez 63 ans et
les 43 années d'amitié requises nous
avons aussi souhaité travailler sur les
seniors parce que une réforme des
retraites nous l'avions d'ailleurs
indiqué lors de du dernier PLFSS doit
s'accompagner d'une véritable politique
de maintien et d'embauche des seniors
c'est quand même incroyable que dans un
pays comme le nôtre on soit aussi peu
efficace sur ce plan là notamment par
rapport à l'expertise que porte les
anciens dans une entreprise et qu'ils
peuvent transmettre au futur générations
et notamment aux apprentis qui sont
aujourd'hui importants en termes de
nombre et qui ont besoin aussi de cette
transmission de ce passage de témoin et
donc à l'initiative de René Paul Savary
qui a beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet
nous avons proposé un panier d'outils à
une boîte à outils pour justement
permettre cette amélioration concernant
le maintien et l'embauche des seniors
dans les entreprises et je laisserai
vous vous
développer ces différentes initiatives
nous avons aussi voulu des marqueurs
concernant la pénibilité et donc vous
avez peut-être regardé les amendements
qui ont été portés par la commission là
encore nous voulons améliorer
la capacité
des entreprises à aménager le temps de
travail ou les postes de travail ou
les carrières des
salariés qui sont en difficulté par
rapport à l'usure professionnelle donc
c'est des dispositions qui sont aussi
très sociales
pour terminer je me tiens à votre
disposition pour les questions
évidemment qui ne manqueront pas de
venir mais moi en tant que rapporteur
j'étais attaché à ce que l'équilibre
soit possible en 2030 donc évidemment
j'ai plutôt été sur cet aspect là alors
ça déshumanise évidemment le discours
parce qu'on sait très bien que une
réforme de retraite je le dis souvent ça
relève de l'intime parce que chacun
revient à sa situation personnelle
individuelle et regarde en fonction de
ce qui est proposé finalement de de ce
qui se passera pour lui-même mais en
réalité notre première générosité
à nous qui sommes aujourd'hui encore
actif c'est de promettre au futur
générations d'avoir cette retraite par
répartition et aujourd'hui la générosité
c'est de faire en sorte que ce système
puisse être financé à moyen terme au
moins à moyen terme puisque 2030 c'est
pour moi un moyen terme après à eux
aussi
aux nouvelles générations de proposer
peut-être des systèmes différents mais
je pense que la retraite par une
partition est sans doute la plus
solidaire puisqu'elle repose sur cette
solidarité générationnelle mais elle
repose aussi sur un fait c'est qu'en
fait le
les retraites quand on regarde les
montants des pensions et bien il y a
moins de pauvreté tant de la retraite
que le temps de l'activité on voit bien
qu'on réduit donc il y a une répartition
même si il y a encore des retraites qui
sont beaucoup trop basses néanmoins
quand on regarde avec la situation des
actifs et bien on réduit cette pauvreté
dès lors qu'on est en retraite donc en
tout cas voilà notre travail a été
intense j'espère que nous pourrons
débattre en séance de de tous ces sujets
qui sont extrêmement importants pour
l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français merci
on va peut-être passer aux questions
juste un point de précision
effectivement par rapport à ça madame la
rapporteur on voit que je voyais pour un
rapporteur général et c'est complètement
inscrit dans les fondamentaux que j'ai
eu l'honneur de lui proposer puisque
c'est on s'est réparti les
responsabilités dans ce test je crois
que vous avez compris la philosophie il
est important quand il y a une longévité
que l'on connaît et tant mieux que l'on
passe de plus de temps à la retraite il
faut que notre société utilise une image
différente par rapport à cette tranche
de vie qui est celle de chacun d'entre
nous et qui fait que il faut pas se
faire la transition entre la fin d'une
activité et le début de la sédentarité
qui va durer un certain nombre d'années
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
fait des propositions allant dans ce
sens là on essaye de remettre les choses
dans ce bon sens dès l'instant où on
peut faire des propositions pour que les
seigneurs sont employés peut-être que à
ce moment-là on peut leur demander de
travailler de façon supplémentaire
est allé sur un nombre d'années où il
est important maintenant que compte tenu
de du rectar qui a pris le gouvernement
pour cette réponse va maintenant on est
obligé d'accélérer le calendrier et puis
il y a cette borne d'âge que l'on veut
modifier de 62 64 ans alors vous me
direz si vous qui connaissez bien les
dispositifs notamment pourquoi touche à
l'âge puisque naturellement la plupart
des gens partent maintenant à
l'orthoplin ils sont déjà à 63 ans avec
le dispositif de la réforme Touraine qui
accélère
la durée de cotisation pour tout le
monde à 43 ans ils vont partir
naturellement pour l'orthoplat à 64 ans
ben écoutez si vous bougez pas large la
borne d'âge et bien les retraités
effectivement risque de partir avant
mais avec des décote qui font que
derrière il y aura pas suffisamment de
revalorisation des pensions et que vous
vous feriez vous faites dans ce
dispositif plein des retraites pauvres
donc la conséquence de l'accélération à
43 ans de la réforme Touraine c'est
l'ajustement de là je légale je tiens à
préciser parce que derrière cela il faut
que pour prendre en compte cet effort
supplémentaire collective demandée à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens hommes et
femmes et bien il faut un certain nombre
de mesures qui prend un prennent en
compte et ils l'ont exprimé dans la rue
leurs difficultés c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons été particulièrement
motivé parce que nous avons entendu ces
maires de famille qui avait l'impression
d'être pas suffisamment bien traitée par
le dispositif proposé nous avons entendu
ceux qui sont usés par le travail et qui
ne sont pas suffisamment prises en
compte puisqu'on décale les âges pour
ceux qui sont en incapacité permanente
ou même dans le dispositif retrait de
progressif c'est pour ça que nous avons
travaillé pour pouvoir dans le cadre
législatif très contraint très contraint
le cas de réglementaire très contraint
essayez de proposer une réforme qui soit
bien plus lisible et acceptable par nos
concitoyens une fois que j'ai dit ça je
pense qu'on peut répondre me semble-t-il
à vos questions
pardon donc Audrey tison France Info
vous avez fait une un certain nombre de
propositions concernant l'emploi des
seniors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer de manière pédagogique s'il
vous plaît
je n'ai pas été donc si si très bien
mais il faut toujours être pédagogique
pour les médias notamment audiovisuels
votre CDI senior et les autres mesures
que vous proposez voilà pour avoir un
oeil nouveau de notre société par
rapport au seniors il faut pour résumer
prendre en compte les seniors qui sont
au chômage
c'est finir sa carrière au chômage et
souvent dans l'après karité c'est pas
acceptable il faut prendre encore les
seniors qui continuent à être en
activité et encore plus longtemps avec
le décalage de l'âge et puis il faut
prendre en compte ceux qui commencent un
peu à peiner et trouver que c'est un peu
long et qui demande à bénéficier d'un
certain nombre de mesures en ce qui
concerne les seigneurs au chômage nous
proposons le CDI
seniors c'est quoi c'est comme un CDI
chantier je prends volontiers cette
métaphore parce que ça exprime bien
quand vous construisez une autoroute il
vous faut 5 5 7 8 ans mais là c'est
pareil quand vous êtes sur la fin de
carrière il y a une contractualisation
entre l'employeur et l'employé pour
définir jusque le taux plein de la
personne ou ils veulent actuellement son
âge de des codes pourquoi pas mais un
contrat qui dit monsieur je vous garde
qui dit Monsieur ou Madame d'ailleurs je
vous garde jusqu'au bout jusqu'au moment
où vous pouvez bénéficier tout à fait
légitimement de votre retraite en
conséquence éventuellement je vais
adapter en fonction vos heures de
travail ou bien les conditions de
travail en contrepartie pour inciter
l'employeur à embaucher ce senior nous
proposons une exonération de la
cotisation familiale pour les seniors
qui sont en activité qui sont encore
employés mais qui ont un certain nombre
de difficultés nous proposons de laisser
à le temps pour ceux qui sont
véritablement reconnus dans le cadre
d'une usure professionnelle le départ à
la retraite anticipée où nous proposons
surtout la retraite progressive de façon
à ce que des 60 ans et non 62 ans comme
proposé dans le texte il puisse entrer
en retraite progressive et finir cette
fin carrière ma foi peut-être à 80 % 80
% salaire 20% retraite de façon à aller
jusqu'au taux plein vous voyez c'est un
dispositif ou en contrepartie de
l'effort supplémentaire demandée pour
travailler on a quelque part une
reconnaissance parce que à ce moment là
la personne aura son taux plein donc une
meilleure retraite
précision sur le CDI senior c'est quand
on signe un CDI après une certaine date
c'est pas quand on est déjà en activité
c'est on manque vous êtes au chômage
vous êtes au chômage j'ai bien dit voilà
le CDI senior c'est pour celui qui est
au chômage arrivé un certain âge nous
avons fixé à 60 ans 60 ans pourquoi
parce que actuellement vous voyez qu'il
y a un pic dans le chômage à 60 ans par
rapport à l'âge de 62 ans à l'âge légal
parce que beaucoup il y a beaucoup de
ruptures conventionnelles et d'ailleurs
nous avons
confirmé la proposition de l'Assemblée
nationale une des rats beaucoup de
propositions qui ont été votées de
mettre à 30% le forfait social sur les
ruptures conventionnelles de façon à la
lignée sur les ruptures pour retraite de
façon à ce que on puisse plutôt choisir
un dispositif de retraite progressive ou
on a quelques autres mesures techniques
mais ne rencontrons pas dans le détail
c'est un petit peu compliqué plutôt que
la rupture conventionnelle
on avait pour les carrières longues on a
vu à l'assemblée qui a eu beaucoup de
débats et très peu de clarification vous
pensez pourquoi sur les 20 21 ans les 17
ans aussi qu'est-ce qui a été décidé en
commission ah ben écoutez la Commission
a adopter le dispositif carrière longue
proposé sur le texte du Gouvernement qui
dit je le rappelle pour ces carrières
longues Trois Bornes une borne à 16 ans
à 18 ans et à 20 ans les deux premières
porns vous avez une durée de cotisation
plus un an la deuxième board 18 ans une
durée de cotisation plus un an et une
durée de cotisation pour la borne de 20
ans qui est la durée de cotisation des
43 ans voilà donc on est arrivé sur ce
texte là à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
eu des avancées de fait qui n'ont pas
été votées puisqu'ils sont pas arrivés
jusque cet article 8 et qui font que la
première ministre a accepté n'a pas
accepté à proposer à proposer certes une
demande de certains mais à proposer de
mettre une quatrième borne voilà donc on
attend l'amendement éventuellement du
gouvernement dans ce dispositif
dispositif là pour mettre la quatrième
board à 21 ans et puis également il y a
eu la première ministre a pris des
engagements concernant les durées
nécessaires pour ces bornes là et c'est
si j'ai bien compris elle a proposé que
ce soit 43 ans pour tout le monde quel
que soit les bornes d'âge
à ce moment là il y a plus de carrière
long si c'est 43 ans et les carrières
précoces mais il y a plus de carrière là
bon contact et ce sont des dispositifs
de plus en plus on vous propose des
agents anticipés de départ bon c'est une
réforme qui doit faire travailler plus
longtemps les gens et dans ces
dispositifs on vous propose de pas les
faire travailler plus longtemps et même
de façon anticiper donc acte c'est de la
responsabilité de la première ministre
on va voir ce qu'elle nous présente nous
nous sommes ouverts aux discussions pour
faire en sorte que l'on trouve le plus
de justice possible et ce qui est
important dans ce dispositif c'est que
soit pris en compte ceux qui travaillent
de bonheur c'est notamment qui sont par
la filière apprentissage parce que ces
gens-là ils ont commencé ils ont des
métiers qui sont sûrement plus
difficiles que celui qui a fait des
études j'en fais partie je peux en
parler et qui commence un peu plus
longtemps mais qui ont peut-être une
pénibilité un peu différente par rapport
à ceux qui ont les notamment des
carrières plus manuelles et voilà donc
il faut pas perdre d'objectif cela parce
que si on est là je lui déborde on perd
un peu les objectifs de départ et on
arrive de toute façon dans les
dispositifs proposés mais qui sont après
par voir réglementaire à ne pas
satisfaire tout le monde parce que même
si on dit que la durée d'âge assurance
requise sera de 43 ans pour tout le
monde même les bornes quand vous
regardez les dispositifs de bornes vous
avez des gens qui auront 40 ans voilà
donc ça ne répond pas à toutes les
préoccupations on emprunte on verra
maintenant ce que nous propose le
gouvernement par rapport à ces carrières
longues nous la Commission on a
travaillé sur le texte ce qui nous ont
proposé donc trois bornes et des durées
telles que je vous les ai précisés
pardonnez-moi de la complexité mais ces
dispositifs sont tels que il est bien
difficile de les faire bien sûr
comprendre par nos concitoyens parce que
ça parfois ils sont même
incompréhensibles pour nous
quand on rentre dans le texte
au cours des discussions
[Musique]
et est-ce qu'il a évoqué à nouveau parce
que à l'Assemblée les débats a été
vraiment pas très clair les propositions
de bornes ou des propositions du
ministre du socle on a rien compris ou
pas compris grand chose dans tous les
cas pas lever les doutes est-ce que le
gouvernement était plus clair avec vous
sur cet aspect là alors pour l'instant
nous les avons dit que nous étions
sensibles à ce dispositif qu'il fallait
semble-t-il l'éclaircir par rapport à ce
qu'il y avait été annoncé donc nous
attendons maintenant les propositions
qui vont être faites et voir surtout si
il déposent des amendements similaires à
ceux qui avaient
déposé à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
n'ont pas été examinés puisqu'ils sont
arrêtés avant donc aujourd'hui on n'a
pas l'incertitude de l'action que fera
le gouvernement faut lui poser la
question au gouvernement c'est pas nous
qu'il faut la poser on va voir la façon
dont il souhaite modifier ce texte
Article 8
article 8 non négociations à ce jour ne
sont qu'avec les conseillers de Matignon
et de des messages de travail on aura
on aura des négociations sans doute
demain avec le ministre puisque nous
devons le rencontrer en fin d'après-midi
mais ces histoires de retraite anticipée
pour carrière longue sont extrêmement
techniques et difficiles à comprendre
parce que il y a la borne d'âge mais il
y a aussi le nombre d'annuités et puis
il y a effectivement l'idée que quand on
parle de carrière longue il faut
effectivement qu'elle soit longue or
aller jusqu'à 21 ans c'est quand même
déjà coûteux et je me demande si on
parle vraiment de carrière longue parce
que avant 20 ans oui c'est des carrières
longues mais après 20 ans là on peut
déjà se poser la question parce que
finalement avec 43 annuités comme c'est
peut-être proposé par le gouvernement là
ça fait pas des carrière longue en fait
c'est des carrières je dirais normal
[Musique]
voilà c'est pareil vous avez bien
compris le dispositif de 4 à 5
trimestres avant l'année la fin de
l'année
je rappelle
dans les détails peut-être mais c'est
quand même important que les trimestres
cotisés qui sont pris en dans les 43 ans
du récapitulisation pervers donc ce sont
pas les mêmes que ceux qui sont pris
dans le code 33 ans pour une carrière
normale il y a moins de solidarité donc
attention plus vous élargissez ce
dispositif moins plus il est
inégalitaire c'est pour ça que ça mérite
réflexion donc on attend les précisions
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ça comme c'est
le gouvernement c'est une réforme c'est
une proposition c'est deux propositions
coûtent 700 millions d'euros
à l'horizon 2030 700 millions d'euros à
l'horizon 2030 donc il appartient au
gouvernement de voir comment dans le cas
d'une réforme budgétaire il dégrade le
rendement de sa réforme c'est pas de la
les engagements
nous on lui a fait part de nos remarques
sur ces sur ce sujet enfin on a fait par
au Cabinet des des remarques que l'on
avait par rapport en effet à ces
engagements pris sur les bornes d'âge et
sur la borne de 21 ans à la fois par
rapport au coût important que cela
générer et comme l'a dit René Paul
Savary par rapport aussi au caractère un
peu inégalitaire de ces mesures après
après c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement le confirmer donne
confirmer on verra le texte qui nous
vient
du gouvernement est-ce que propose en
effet le Gouvernement sur ce dispositif
carrière longue nous on a fait part de
nos remarques de nos interrogations
après en fonction de ce qui arrivera on
verra ce que l'on fait
donc
vous dites 700 millions les deux chacune
des deux mesures c'est les deux mesures
700 millions 400 et 300 400 et 300
redites moi les deux mesures c'est la
carrière longue à 20h Laborde à 21 ans
c'est la bonne à 21 ans
à 43 ans
selon vos dates de naissance il y en a
qui ont 43 il y en a encore en 44 c'est
un dispositif me semble-t-il il faudrait
entrer en revoir
il faut savoir que la loi était fini les
bornes mais tout le reste radio
réglementaire c'est du décret c'est du
décret donc de même l'affectation à
chaque borne de la durée d'âge est un
décret également donc c'est de la
responsabilité
du gouvernement ça mais maintenant il
faut qu'il nous disent de ce qu'il veut
faire quand même on ne vous sent très
enthousiaste à défendre cette mesure
qu'on peut résumer comme l'amendement
Pradier est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes
pour cette mesure et ben écoutez la
Commission a travaillé sur ce texte au
débat on aura l'occasion de s'exprimer
je m'exprimais à titre de rapporteur et
que je m'exprimais également à titre
personnel personnellement si vous me le
demandez aujourd'hui oui je dis cette
mesure est inégalitaire je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on rentre service à travers ce
dispositif des personnes qui sont
actuellement dans cette tâche concernée
c'est-à-dire avoir 4 à 5 trimestre avant
la fin de l'année de leurs 20 ans
pourquoi parce que le système est
nettement moins solidaire et que la
personne qui est en pleine peau comme
vous et moi qui fait sa carrière
continue qui a pas connu les périodes de
chômage etc et ben cette portière là
cette personne là elle boa partir à 63
ans celui qui est fragile et il est
malade le maladies chroniques et ses
médecins qui parlent quelqu'un de
courageux qui va vaincre la maladie
retourner au travail en taux d'eux avoir
des périodes comme ça et ben c'est de
ces indemnités journalières qui vont
compter pour sa retraite celui-là il
part à 60 il part à 64 ans je trouve que
plus on élargit les bornes d'un système
inégalitaire plus s'il y en a de
bénéficiaires et moins on est solidaire
c'est pour ça que ça mérite une
réflexion qui n'a pas été poussée me
semble-t-il par le gouvernement au
moment où il a proposé ce dispositif qui
est venu se rajouter sur quelque chose
qui était un peu mieux construit au
départ pardon pour être précis vous donc
ce qui vous dérange pour être bien
précis
c'est c'est pas forcément que certains
bénéficient d'une carrière longue c'est
les dispositions des carrières longues
ces fameux quatre trimestres qui font
que ça exclut mais il suffit qu'à trois
trimestres il rentre pas dedans etc il
faut que ça exclut c'est d'accord c'est
pas la justice décidait à travers ce
dispositif c'est des soustractions
quelque sorte qu'apportent les
conditions
je suis pas convaincu quand on ne
servisse à ces personnes là de les faire
rentrer dans ce type de dispositif ils
vont vite en sortir dès l'instant ils
ont un instant ils ont ils ont une
fragilité au cours de leur carrière et
Dieu sait que maintenant on sait bien
que les carrières elles sont plus
continues comme avant que on peut
également tomber malade et puis les
progrès médicaux font que maintenant
même malade on arrive à travailler on
vit plus longtemps c'est pas du tout la
même approche que celle que l'on a connu
jusqu'à présent et je pense que ce
dispositif il est has been faut le
revoir c'est un dispositif carrière
précoce qui mériterait une réécriture
complète c'est ce que j'aurais versé
du gouvernement ou ce que nous aurions
proposé dans le cas de nos textes mais
sûrement pas ces mesures là maintenant
dans tact c'est de la responsabilité un
Premier ministre qui s'exprime qui
disent je vais faire ça maintenant ben
moi je comprends qu'il revienne en
disant bah oui on tape nous on va pas
voilà hein il doit le faire maintenant
hein alors on va lui demander
déclarification mais si vous voulez je
parle sous le contrôle de
creux des comptes
c'est un dispositif particulièrement
cher quand même alors quand équivalent
en compte du dispositif a demandé du
travail supplémentaire aux gens puisque
on leur donne des bornes pour partir
moins longtemps donc c'est un
compréhensible et nos concitoyens
simple oui Elisée Cardi de Public Sénat
justement quand on vous écoute on a
l'impression on a l'impression que voilà
vous allez bouger à chaque fois des
curseurs et que on va créer des
nouvelles dépenses finalement
l'équilibre budgétaire il est
extrêmement difficile à trouver sur ce
texte les marches du Sénat sont très
faibles du fait des engagements pris qui
sont des engagements particulièrement
couteux mais dans les dispositions que
nous prenons il y a des dispositifs qui
donnent des recettes supplémentaires
vous prenez le forfait social qui sera
plus important vous prenez des actions
comme sur la capacité permanente qui
sera prise sur la branche ATMP et non
pas sur la branche vieillesse et nous
avons effectivement des dispositifs qui
sont qui coûtent un petit peu de sous
quand même
la retraite progressive notamment ça
coûte un petit peu de sous ou une autre
dispositif par rapport à la prise en
compte des carrières de maire de famille
avec la surcotte qui est vraiment un
beau dispositif me semble-t-il et ben ça
coûte effectivement quelque part mais si
vous voulez il faut bien quand même
rendre cette réforme acceptable et il
est tout à fait légitime de prendre en
compte les préoccupations qui ont été
exprimées me semble-t-il dans la rue
quand même hein ben justement parlons-en
cette réforme elle est elle est elle est
très décriée dans le pignon public
comment vous réagissez vous face à ça
face à une opinion qui est en majorité
opposée à la réforme on va dire vous
savez c'est d'une complexité une oui moi
je comprends bien que les gens quand
vous demandez aux gens de travailler
plus c'est naturel vous avez pas on n'a
pas le sentiment on va pas sauter sur sa
chaise en disant youpi qu'est-ce que
c'est bien
quand vous proposez ça en Suisse vous
faites un référendum il est voté pour
travailler de façon supplémentaire quand
vous moi j'étais voir le dispositif en
Suède il y a déjà 5 ans avec Jean-Paul
Delvoye les Suédois nous disaient chez
nous quand on a parlé on a augmenté
l'âge de 2 ans il y a même pas eu un
article dans les journaux bah en France
c'est pas pareil on a eu une vision du
travail qui est un petit peu différente
et c'est vrai qu'il faut prendre en
compte non seulement la durée mais
également mieux pouvoir travailler il
faut concilier tout ça je pense que
notre réforme amène un peu les
dispositifs je pense que la réforme
devrait être suivie elle aurait pu être
précédée d'ailleurs mais elle devrait
être suivie du noix sur le travail pour
compléter en effet tout ce qu'on vient
de dire sur l'emploi des seniors sur la
qualité du au travail il y a eu des
textes il y a eu des textes sur la santé
au travail mais il y a encore besoin de
compléter
moi ce que je regrette pour vous le dire
c'est c'est que le gouvernement Macron
est le président Macron est la depuis 6
ans attendre 6 ans après le début de son
mandat pour après nous avoir vendu comme
pendant deux ans avec Édouard Philippe
et Jean-Paul Delevoye une réforme qui
était soi-disant la réforme du siècle
nous on trouve que c'était compliqué à
chaque fois on nous balayait avec une
forme de condescendance en disant mais
vous ne comprenez rien c'est sans doute
trop compliqué pour vous parce que vous
n'êtes pas assez intelligent pour la
comprendre mais total elle est au Sénat
ils n'ont pas reprise donc c'est à dire
depuis six ans nous a baladé sur une
réforme universelle qui n'a pas été
décidé et je comprends un peu les
Français d'abord quand on dit le
président de la République à 200 dire
l'inverse de ce qui dit maintenant de se
dire mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi on nous la propose nous on est
constant pour la proposer depuis des
années et c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
mouvements dans la rue qu'on va revenir
sur cette constance tous nos candidats à
la présidentielle avait proposé des une
réforme des retraites
que notre famille la vote je veux dire
ça ce qui me paraîtrait ahurissant si je
puis dire c'est de faire un salto
arrière là ça bouge on retourne aux
abris non c'est pas la position que le
Sénat choisi même face à la position de
l'opposition syndicale mais bien sûr
bien sûr je veux dire ce pays crève de
réforme qui ne sont jamais faites on a
une dette publique qui colle sale c'est
un déficit public et colossal moi je
veux bien Pierre Moscovici que président
la Cour des comptes et président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques nous a
expliqué ce qui était la dette nous l'a
expliqué c'est pas quelqu'un de droite
je sache il nous a expliqué ce qui était
la dette on a une dette qu'une dépense
totalement
inutile chaque année on dépense des
milliards et des milliards alors qu'on a
des systèmes qui partent à volo la santé
par un volo l'éducation paravolo la
justice a besoin de moyens on a besoin
de moyens on a besoin d'investissement
et non bouge pas parce que bah oui parce
que c'est difficile parce que c'est
compliqué puis parce que c'est pas le
moment bon moi je veux bien tout mais
c'est pas ma conception de la politique
et travailler plus longtemps donc c'est
le sens de la plus longtemps bien sûr
il travaille déjà 63 ans donc ils vont
pas travailler 2 ans plus ils vont
travailler quelques mois plus on vit
beaucoup plus longtemps il y avait
quatre actifs pour un retraité il y a
quelques années il y en a un peu plus
d'un maintenant
à qui on fait plaisir là on fait pas
plaisir nous ce qu'on veut c'est que les
jeunes en effet puissent avoir un
système qui tienne la route le système
par répartition auquel on est attaché
qui tiennent la route moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse qu'on fasse pas on fait rien
on fait rien bah vogue la galère non
mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit que une
réforme sur le temps de travail il faut
que ce soit accompagné de mesures fortes
sur l'emploi des seniors est-ce que vous
pensez que l'index senior ou le CDI
senior peut suffire finalement résoudre
cette question là où est-ce qu'il
faudrait aussi d'autres choses je
voudrais revenir sur votre première
question moi je comprends la colère et
l'anxiété des Françaises et des Français
qui sont dans la rue parce que de toute
façon à chaque réforme des retraites il
y a eu aussi ces démonstrations de la
part des de nos concitoyens et moi je la
comprends vraiment parfaitement parce
que c'est faire des efforts et demander
des efforts c'est toujours compliqué
pourquoi c'est c'est difficile en plus à
cette période d'abord parce que on est
dans une période post covid et que
chacun des Français s'est posé la
question du sens qu'il mettait dans le
travail dans ses loisirs dans son temps
de retraite et et que pour certains
effectivement le temps du travail c'est
peut-être de la peine au travail pour
d'autres c'est de la joie aussi certains
ont manqué de travail pendant les
périodes de confinement on a eu aussi
ces démonstrations là et donc chacun
s'est posé ces questions là et puis il y
a si le fait que sur le pouvoir d'achat
les Français aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté à cause de l'énergie à cause
de des augmentations sur l'alimentaire
le contexte n'est pas bon donc moi je
comprends qu'il y ait cette réaction
cependant je crois que je voulais dit
tout à l'heure nous sommes tous attachés
à ce système par répartition et ne doute
nous devons
accepter que au vu des données
démographiques nous
demandions quelques efforts parce que
c'est très facile à chacune à chacun
d'entre nous de regarder sur le plan
familial
nos parents connaissaient leurs
grands-parents nous a déjà notre âge on
a pu connaître nos arrières
grands-parents et les générations qui
viennent connaîtront au moins cinq
générations et pour autant on a moins
d'enfants par famille et donc on voit
bien que
les retraités en fait pour assurer le
retraite il y a qu'un virgule 7
difficile de saucissonner mais c'est la
qualité 1,7 actif et mais on l'observe
dans nos familles c'est une réalité donc
sur le plan démographique ces
catastrophique donc on doit réagir pour
justement maintenir ce système par
répartition qui je dis est plus
solidaire qu'un autre système on peut on
pourra parler sans doute pendant ces 15
jours de d'appoint ou d'une retraite par
capitalisation mais celle qu'il faut
préserver avant tout c'est celle par
répartition qui atténue et qui diminue
justement les les comment les injustices
vous vous disiez tout à l'heure aussi
vous avez une question les mesures les
seniors
ce sont des c'est une voix tracée est-ce
que c'est pas mettre la charrue avant
les deux ou prendre les jeux à l'envers
c'est vraiment excusez-moi puisque c'est
moi qui ai proposé ça mais je l'ai pas
inventé le CDI seniors c'est parce que
j'ai écouté c'est des amendements que
j'ai trouvé pour certains non
donc c'est cotise donc nous sommes
d'accord nous essayons de tracer une
voie de donner des perspectives que le
Seigneur au chômage il puisse se dire ah
ben moi j'ai peut-être une chance de
travailler parce que celui-là il y en a
qui ont été mis sur cette voie là et ben
je peux vous dire que ils sont pas
heureux forcément donc ils sont à
travers un dispositif ils peuvent
retrouver un espoir de rentrer dans la
dimension travail ça redonne confiance
aux chefs d'entreprise disons les
seniors finalement c'est des gens
fidèles on avait fait l'étude sur
l'emploi des seniors les jeunes
voulaient te faire une formation etc et
on les comprend il change le métier le
truc le Seigneur lui il est fidèle quand
même il va rester vous lui faites la
formation adapté on sait pas faire les
formations seniors de nos jours donc
c'est une voix c'est dans la loi travail
qu'il faudra vraiment affiner ce type de
dispositif nous en sommes conscients
mais si on rentre pas la voix vous voyez
bien que rien n'était proposé donc c'est
toujours mieux que rien parce que nous
proposons
une question sur les régimes spéciaux je
sais que ça n'a pas été débattu en
commission enfin le votre idée de faire
converger plus rapidement d'aller plus
rapidement à 64 ans pour tous ça va être
porté par les républicains par un
amendement de groupe c'est ça écoutez à
chaque jour suffisait appelle pour
l'instant nous on est là donc le groupe
va réfléchir effectivement il y a des
réflexions dans le groupe également de
mais on va harmoniser tout ça toujours
est-il que si vous voulez le dispositif
proposé par le gouvernement et une
fermeture de ces régimes spéciaux dans
80 ans c'est la clause du grand-père
quand vous calculez
nous nous étions à dire qu'il fallait
une convergence dans depuis quatre ans
toujours dans la même certitude de dire
il faut une convergence des régimes des
régimes spéciaux sur les dispositifs du
régime commun
on proposait un délai à l'époque il faut
remonter à 5 ans et peut-être un petit
peu brutal qui serait pas compréhensif
qui est trop court mais entre 80 ans et
5 6 ans et 15 20 ans on peut peut-être
faire une harmonisation même sur 15 ans
20 ans moi je suis très ouvert à un
délai mais pas 70 ans c'est pas sérieux
que de dire qu'on va fermer les régimes
spéciaux parce que c'est dans 80 ans
vous voyez prendre des dispositions qui
concerne panneau concitoyens qui vont
concerner les suivants ma foi c'est un
peu la réforme Touraine vous voyez on a
dit bah oui c'est pas trop mal passé
vous avez travaillé 43 ans mais
rassurez-vous elle commence à réforme
Touraine date de 2012 on est en 2023
elle commence elle vient de commencer
depuis un an ou deux donc elle va
s'appliquer jusqu'à la génération
normalement 73 là elle est anticipé et
prendre des dispositions qui concernent
les suivants bah oui on va dire oui
finalement personne n'est dans la rue à
ce moment-là sauf que quand vous
commencez à être concerné c'est pas le
même dispositif nous on est assumé nos
responsabilités voilà
et on a proposé déjà depuis des lustres
certains nombre de vos collègues à
l'Assemblée en off aux quatre colonnes
nous disaient peut-être que au moins
symboliquement on aurait dû associer les
entreprises là on demande un effort ou
salarié et uniquement aux salariés et on
ne demande pas d'efforts même
symboliques aux entreprises depuis des
années il y a eu énormément de gains de
productivité aux entreprises dans les
entreprises c'est gains de productivité
sont très rarement aller au salaire on
voit depuis quelques mois
[Musique]
des vrais
sur profit dans un certain nombre de
secteurs d'activités et c'est très
difficile de lesigner quand même donc
est-ce que vous vous estimez que il
aurait pu y avoir dans ce projet de loi
un effort demandé aux entreprises un
effort de cotisation sur les retraites
de manière à ce que les salariés n'aient
pas l'impression d'être les seuls à qui
on demande un effort oui il faut que les
entreprises participent à l'effort
collectif mais pas forcément par des
cotisations supplémentaires il y a
d'autres dispositifs qui peuvent être là
leur proposer effectivement des outils
pour embaucher les seniors et qu'ils le
font pas c'est là que vous pouvez
prendre des dispositifs coercitifs mais
encore faut-il avant de faire des
coercition avoir proposé des dispositifs
incitatifs c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons fait les propositions qui
sont les nôtres mais moi je comprends ne
concitoyens il y a ce problème de
rapport au travail
et bien le problème de rapport à
l'argent quand on vous a inculqué et
qu'on pouvait vivre à crédit comme on
vit à crédit qu'on a fait le quoi qu'il
en coûte où on a brassé des milliards et
des milliards qu'on entend les profits
des supers entreprises qui bravent des
milliards quelque part quand on vous dit
que votre système de retraite il est
déficitaire d'une dizaine de milliards
en 2030
vous vous dites mais attendez il se
moque de moi quoi un véritablement c'est
ce rapport à l'argent qui est terrible
nos concitoyens non plus la dimension
l'État providence ça n'existe pas faut
retomber sur terre un bien de comprendre
donc nous nous proposerons aux
entreprises effectivement des mesures
incitatives dans la loi travail je crois
qu'elles seront toutes les dispositions
pour faire en sorte de pouvoir enlever
embaucher davantage notamment de seniors
et il appartiendra moi je partage votre
point de vue de mettre des mesures
coercitives à ce moment-là vous voyez on
voit plutôt les choses comme ça moi je
pense que le niveau de cotisation en
France est déjà l'un des plus élevés au
monde et qu'on peut pas aller au delà
par contre et puis en plus ça ça
s'applique sur toutes les entreprises
qu'elles soient petit ou grandes qu'elle
fasse des petits ou des grands profits
et donc pour moi c'est c'est en tout cas
c'est quelque chose de rédhibitoire moi
je veux pas d'augmentation de cotisation
par contre qu'on s'intéresse
effectivement
au profit des entreprises on a eu un
certain nombre de contexte pour
justement que les salariés puissent
bénéficier aussi des rapports de
rendement des entreprises et ça se fait
aussi
suffisamment souvent il y a des accords
mais mais oui mais ça il faudra
l'inciter il faut il faudra le faire il
faudra le faire ouais ouais mais ça il
faudra que que
celle qui font des bénéfices et qu'elle
puisse partager ses bénéfices avec leurs
salariés ça me semble d'une grande
cohérence et justement ça permet au
niveau du pouvoir d'achat des salariés
d'avoir voilà des vrais perspectives et
puis ça ça c'est une juste gratification
des efforts qu'ils ont pu fournir pour
atteindre ces montants de bénéfices et
je pense que là dessus il faudra
travailler en réalité la réforme des
retraites elle est comment dirais-je
compliqué à prendre effectivement dans
un contexte où on n'a pas anticipé sur
qu'est-ce que on voulait organiser comme
parcours
parcours professionnel alors une loi
travail aurait été bénéfique mais une
loi qui vraiment s'intéresse notamment à
tous les âges il y a quelques années ce
gouvernement a fait des propositions
ingénieur une solution là on fait une
proposition un seigneur une solution
mais la véritable
préoccupation qu'on devrait avoir c'est
tous cet ensemble quelle vision d'avenir
sur le travail
on devrait avoir et c'est vrai que cette
réforme elle est budgétaire elle est
comment rendu acceptable par quelques
mesures sociales de justice qui sont qui
sont à mon sens important pour celle
qu'elle qui sont concernées mais c'est
vrai que il aurait fallu doubler ça
d'une d'une vraie comment réflexion sur
qu'est-ce que le temps de travail
qu'est-ce qu'on considère le temps de la
retraite parce que on voit bien dans
dans une dans un des articles et aussi
le cumul emploi retraite on en a pas
parlé on ouvre des droits désormais à
ceux qui cotisent alors qu'ils ont
atteint voilà un âge l'âge de la
retraite donc ça c'est c'est important
aussi vous le voyez bien on donne une
borne d'âge d'ouverture des droits mais
en fait on s'est rendu compte par
exemple dans les auditions qu'on a fait
auprès des régimes spéciaux c'est que
beaucoup par terre beaucoup plus tard
que ces tâches d'ouverture de retraite
donc
ce qui serait bien c'est finalement le
choix le choix pour l'ensemble des
Français mais de toute façon il serait
forcément borné pour le rendre et qui à
l'équilibre mais mais on voit bien que
déjà les Français choisissent quand même
là auquel ils prennent leur retraite
parce que soit parce qu'ils ont commencé
tard soit parce qu'ils ont eu des
carrières hachées et qui veulent
compléter leur retraite par un cumul
emploi retraite donc il y a aussi ça
ouais ouais ils ont il y en a qui ont
envie de de continuer à travailler les
médecins c'est un exemple pendant la
crise covid on a vu qu'ils se sont
mobilisés pour beaucoup auprès auprès
des équipes
même des infirmières
faut savoir que
dans le dispositif
dans le dispositif de carrière anticipée
et derrière quand vous prenez ceux qui
font accumul emploi retraite vous avez
20 à 30 % de ces personnes qui sont
accumules en poids retraite qui ont
bénéficié d'un âge anticipé de départ
durée de cotisation voilà l'homme est
ainsi fait l'homme sur le plan générique
que il y a pas de façon d'encaisser les
choses de façon
identique voilà donc il y en a qui ont
plus de fragilité que d'autres donc ce
qui nous importe nous si on demande un
effort supplémentaire c'est que la
fragilité de certains soit quand même
mieux prise en compte que ce qui nous
est proposé mais ce sera pas moi je le
dis à titre personnel ce sera pas la
réforme de mes rêves c'est pas ça que
j'aurais proposé mais c'est quand même
une réforme qui amène un certain nombre
d'avancées et qui nous fait quand même
montrer la réalité réalité d'un
dispositif par répartition qui si on n'y
prend pas garde ne serait pas pérenne si
les mesures ne courageuses n'étaient pas
prises à temps il y a déjà du retard
trop de retard mais il faut pas
l'accentuer pour compléter ce que je
vous ai dit parce que j'ai répondu de
toute façon un peu brutale peut-être
mais c'est évident que ce n'est pas le
bon moment je veux dire on a une crise
internationale qui angoissante on sort
d'une période de covid dont on voit les
conséquences psychologiques quel que
soit les âges d'ailleurs aussi bien sur
les jeunes que sur les personnes âgées
donc c'est vrai que ce n'est pas le bon
moment il y a la crise énergétique et
tout ça mais reculer encore fait que ce
sera encore plus compliqué et c'est pour
ça où nous on prend nos responsabilités
par rapport à ça il est vrai que
demander à des gens de travailler plus
longtemps lorsqu'ils sont épanouis dans
leur emploi parce qu'il y a une qualité
de vie au travail ce n'est pas du tout
la même chose lorsque les gens je pense
qu'en effet dans ce pays on est allé
faire un déplacement en Suède on le voit
dans des pays où ils travaillent on sent
dans les entreprises que l'on a visité
qui a un effort important sur la qualité
de vie au travail sur l'accompagnement
des salariés on le voit moi j'ai fait la
commission d'enquête sur l'hôpital on
voit combien au delà des rémunérations
des soignants au delà ce qu'elle demande
aussi c'est des facilités dans leur
exercice de leur métier de soignant dans
le logement dans la carte d'enfants dans
tout ça des sujets qu'on a souvent
laissé de côté en France qui est
peut-être des sujets plus anglo-saxons
je ne sais pas que d'autres mais là
dessus il faut revenir dessus il faut
vraiment travailler dessus parce que
c'est aussi plus facile de demander aux
gens de travailler un peu plus longtemps
lorsqu'ils sont bien dans leur emploi ça
c'est évident c'est le cas pour tout le
monde donc vous dites qu'en fait la
réforme telle qu'elle est présentée vous
n'êtes pas complètement fan à 100% mais
vous êtes prêt à l'assumer face à face à
une opinion publique qui sera finalement
opposée on parle de la journée du 7 mars
qui risque d'être quand même
bien sûr qu'on l'assume parce qu'on
correspond quand même grosso modo à ce
qu'on vote à chaque manifestation
est-ce que vous avez peur que ça
perturbe les débats dans l'hémicycle
cette journée du 7 mars et d'autres plus
tard
moi je me suis même pas posé la question
de l'avoir peur ou pas certains me
disent ils me disait faites attention
quand vous rentrez chez vous ça ne
m'avait même pas effleurer quoi l'idée
puisse me faire attaquer si je rentre
chez moi bon la question c'est est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à l'assumer face à
une opinion publique qui peut encore se
durcir en fait bien sûr
on essaye de la rendre un peu plus
acceptable par des dispositifs mais on
sait bien que ce sera particulièrement
difficile contenu du contexte ce type de
réforme c'est des réformes de début de
quinquennat c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le
début parce que dans le début il y a pas
les mêmes la peine approche et un
gouvernement qui a été élu sur un
programme bien fixe et tout on démarre
on y va là on voit bien que c'est un peu
plus compliqué parce que depuis il y a
un contexte tel que effectivement vous
prenez le covid on a creusé les
inégalités entre ceux qui pouvaient
bénéficier du télétravail travailler
chez eux et puis celui qui fait un
métier manuel bah lui il est resté et
puis après il faut on voit bien que ces
inégalités sont creusées on a parlé du
quoi qu'il en coûte la vision globale
qui font que ça tombe effectivement le
plus mauvais moment il n'empêche que les
réponses impopulaire c'est jamais le bon
moment une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
bien assumer ses responsabilités on doit
donner un chemin on l'aurait mieux
expliqué ça nous aurait simplifié la
tâche bon on aurait pris un peu des
dispositions aussi autre pour ça aurait
été mieux on aurait commencé par la loi
travail ça aurait été mieux bon tac
maintenant nous on travaille sur la loi
qu'on nous propose on essaie de
l'arranger comment vous l'a dit après
c'est au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités et de voir ce qu'il veut
faire derrière et puis pour la
légitimité bon moi Dieu sait si je ne
suis pas une
un soutien très fort d'Emmanuel Macron
soutien d'Emmanuel Macron on ne peut pas
lui dénier le fait que dans son
programme il avait retraite à 65 ans il
a été élu il a la légitimité pour
appliquer cette réforme quand j'entends
dire que cette réforme est illégitime
non je ne suis pas un soutien d'Emmanuel
Macron mais je confirme qu'il a la
légitimité pour appliquer ce qu'il avait
mis dans son programme on peut pas dire
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de débats on peut
pas dire qu'il y a eu beaucoup de choses
mais néanmoins il y avait un programme
et ça c'était dans le programme donc
ceux qui disent mais non mais ça c'était
le programme mais on a voté pour lui
mais ça on s'en fiche non il assume ce
qu'il avait dit pour une fois qu'il a
mis dans son programme
est-ce que comment vous apprendez le
rapport avec la gauche qui est fermement
opposé à ce projet
on sait qu'ils veulent pas aller au bout
de la lecture du texte ce qui donnerait
la même chose que ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée même si on discuterait voilà
ils disent qu'ils veulent quand même
discuter des des
articles articles par articles mais qui
ne voudraient pas aller au bout du test
est-ce que vous craignez finalement une
une inconstitutionnalité à la fin et
finalement ça n'est servi à rien tout ça
est-ce que c'est une pensée que vous
n'avez pas je crois que la gauche du
Sénat n'est pas la gauche de l'Assemblée
nationale alors même si on a aujourd'hui
des éléments pour dire que le projet
sera débattu parce qu'il y a un nombre
important d'amendements vous avez sans
doute tout constaté que que ça tombe ça
tombe c'est une pluie il y en a moins
qu'à l'assemblé mais on est déjà rendu à
3000 ou quelque chose comme ça donc
c'est déjà c'est déjà beaucoup pour le
Sénat donc on sent qu'il y a l'envie
d'aller assez lentement sur le début du
texte et d'aller lentement vers cet
article 7 qui est la borne d'âge de
départ en retraite mais pour autant on a
senti en commission un vrai intérêt de
la part de nos collègues de gauche sur
des mesures sociales dont ils veulent
débattre donc
c'est à voir si effectivement il
garderont l'ensemble de ces amendements
au cours de la discussion en tout cas la
majorité satoriale souhaite aller
jusqu'au bout du texte et ça donnera les
moyens
merci
pourquoi le cerveau on compte sur vous